[Musique]
bienvenue dans pas fou nous allons
beaucoup parler de liberté d'expression
avec vincent ohanessian bonjour vous
êtes avocat au barreau de paris et vous
publiez avec emmanuel pierrât 1 comme de
la liberté d'expression va on va en
parler assez longuement dans cette
émission qui regroupe à la fois de tous
les textes la jurisprudence sur la
liberté d'expression et sur les limites
de cette même liberté d'expression pour
en parler avec vous stéphane minson
bonjour patrick compresseur allongées
vers 6 heures dont j'ai manqué d'envié
de voir des gens c'était nous avons
suffisamment répété je sais je suspense
c'est pas dans son professeur à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
florence père cadets choqué vous êtes
avocate vous aussi
mais au bord de versailles dont jean
patrice et jean charles lajoie ni je
n'ai pas hésité puisque c'est un rideau
qui le livre de masse en version b il
vous présidez des éditions l'âge d'homme
absolument on va commencer peut-être
avec eux avec ce livre c'est un livre
très technique il faut pas c'est pas
pour lire au liban techniques mixtes et
des services juridiques qui ont servi
parce qu'une somme râble vous vous
entendez que ce n'est pas le prochain
roman de plage de l'étudiant sur
polémique sur la
l'expression est à n'en pas douter ce
sont tous les outils juridiques
exactement c'est pour ça que ça
s'appelle code c'est un petit clin
d'oeil puisque dans mary code
il a droit lui si des lois qui codifie
mais effectivement comme c'est un
recueil de textes et de jurisprudence il
me semblait il nous semblait avec
emmanuel que le terme code était
appropriée et puis dans le terme code il
ya la notion d' outils même un salaire
de 12 ouvrages qu'on ouvre à la demande
en fait quand on recherche quelque chose
donc c'était vraiment ce qu'on voulait
faire passer et j'espère que je pense
d'ailleurs que c'est un outil très utile
surtout en ce moment
donc tout est vrai dedans c'est du droit
en fait y'a pas de n'y a pas deux si
vous voulez y a pas de l'appréciation
c'est ça il ya passé ce que jolie
personnelles sur des sujets pas c'est
pas un décès votre avis c'est en fait
une compilation mais c'est ça ben en
fait c'est une étrange c'est une
assemblée soit là c'est une synthèse en
fait l'apport c'est déjà de faire la
synthèse de l'organiser manière
thématique
ce qui n'a jamais été fait avant et puis
de fournir un index en fin d ouvrage qui
est quand même assez exhaustif et qui
permet donc de trouver facilement un
texte ou une jurisprudence sur un sujet
donné ou un terme une expression que ce
bouquin qui s'adresse à qui alors il
s'adresse à tous les gens qui sont qui
sont intéressés par la liberté
d'expression c'est à dire les avocats
les étudiants les journalistes et hommes
politiques et syndicalistes les chefs
d'entreprise restreint les magistrats
voilà donc ça fait pas mal de gens et
notamment tous ceux qui à juste titre
s'exprime sur la liberté d'expression et
ont des avis ça permet de recadrer
certaines choses
voilà alors la liberté d'expression les
prévu par des grands textes
au fond le principe oui c'est pour ça
que cet ouvrage il est en deux parties
une partie assez réduite mais qui est la
substantifique moelle puisque la liberté
d'expression c'est le principe
ça c'est une liberté publique la libre
expression donc en début d'ouvragé vous
avez vous trouvé tous les bouquets pour
vous c'est la reine
et libertés - oui je vais à partir du
moment où on peut se réjouir qu en tant
qu être humain on est cette faculté
d'avoir un minimum de conscience
capacité à penser pouvoir l'exprimer de
manière libre pour moi est le signe
[Musique]
le plus beau de ce que peut être une
démocratie tout simplement donc en début
d'ouvragé vous avez des textes de
référence protège en tout cas qui
consacre plutôt la ligue protège aussi
la liberté d'expression et puis ensuite
pour ce qui concerne le droit français
vous avez évidemment sur universelle des
droits de l'homme
évidemment à l'appui après devant mots
des textes des textes qui sont qui sont
un petit peu au prix dans partout où
vous allez et le code civil le code
pénal le code de procédure pénale etc
etc
et puis ensuite par thème toutes les
limites en fait que vous avez à la
liberté d'expression liberté
d'expression qui est prise dans une
acception très larrouy c'est à dire
c'est pas simplement le de l'injure la
diffamation voilà j'ai essayé de mettre
dedans
exactement
et aussi partie sur l'expression forcé
sur des certaines obligations en matière
de publicité etc
voilà donc c'est assez j'espère complet
alors je disais c'est pas un essai pour
compte liberté d'expression mais est-ce
que vous avez l'impression que plus les
fera plus on se rapproche d'une période
et plus les tests qui limite la liberté
d'expression augmentent le nombre de
textes qui évite si vous voulez j'ai
l'expression augmente on souffre alors
particulièrement en france d'une d'une
maladie qui est la législative aiguë qui
veut que de toute façon on aime
fabriquer des textes ça doit passer
c'est comme ça c'est l'esprit français
on aime fabriquer des textes ce qui est
inquiétant c'est que on a tendance à 6
voulait inventer des interdictions
nouvelle pour résoudre des problèmes
c'est vrai dans tous les domaines
j'ai pas un exemple en particulier à
vous donner mais s'est on invente des
interdictions que là bas voilà le
harcèlement de rue par exemple
typiquement qui s'appellera plus comme
ça donc évidemment que c'est un énorme
problème c'est un problème de société
c'est un programme de relations
hommes-femmes c'est un problème
d'éducation ces voix là c'est compliqué
mais voilà on a tout de suite tendance à
dire voilà qu'est ce qu'on va faire on
va on va créer une contravention à
double avec un bon sens il ya un exemple
et un peu aussi comme j'ai dis pas que
je suis contre attention je ne dis pas
je suis pour non plus je ne dis rien les
traces mais voilà comme en avril il ya
eu débat par exemple alors il ya
quelques années sur le les gens qui
expriment et les thèses négationnistes
alors c'est interdit aujourd'hui par là
loin il y avait un débat il n'existe
rien qui disait mais peut-être qu'il
vaut mieux les combattre par l'histoire
la preuve historique que par la loi
c'est vrai on a toujours un débat costa
sûr c'est un débat vraiment compliqué
c'est vrai débat vraiment compliqué de
toute façon j'allais dire dans une
société idéale
on aurait besoin de très peu texte les
gens il a éduqué il respecterait l'autre
il serait qu'il faut pas taper sur son
prochain
ce soit un homme ou une femme etc etc ça
c'est l'idéal
bon ça malheureusement c'est pas ça tout
va comme ça comme ça que ça se passe
donc on est obligé de ces lire
quelquefois de diriger deux de créer des
interdictions mais il faut se méfier et
surtout en matière de liberté
d'expression surtout en matière de
liberté d'expression parce que là on est
au coeur de tout on en parlera
certainement tout à l'heure mais
il faut faire attention de ne pas
glisser dans le délit d'opinion
oui et à mon sens c'est le cas
aujourd'hui dans plein de domaines
voilà à partir du moment où je ne suis
pas d'accord avec mon prochain sur un
sujet qui lui tient à coeur
est-ce que je glisse vers la n2 mon
prochain
est ce que si je les exprime j'incite à
la haine de celui qui pense pas comme
moi je savais qu'elle allait on est on
est on commence à tomber un petit peu là
dedans anglais le site mais je vais
laisser les uns et les autres oui
justement est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que ce n'est pas dans notre
société d'aujourd'hui il ya on est plus
justement dans la juridicisation c'est à
dire d'aller au procès à l'interdiction
que dans le débat est ce que la liberté
d'expression au fond c'est un peu
atténuée oui enfin je pense que les gens
s'autocensurent les gens n'ont quasiment
plus rien dire une sorte de chape de
plomb de politiquement correct qui fait
que sur certains sujets il est même plus
d'opinions exprimées il ya simplement
façon on va rien dire puisque ça
pourrait fâcher telle communauté tel
groupe telle ou telle personne dont on
nous dit de moins en moins de choses
donc la liberté d'expression elle est
enfin le pourrait s'éteindre d'elle-même
ou parce que de toute façon plus
personne ne dit rien tout le monde une
sorte de consensus généralisé
enfin pas pas forcément autour des
tables enfin dans comme énormément de
démissions de deux endroits où les gens
prennent la parole je veux dire c'est
c'est vraiment à fleuret moucheté terre
personne n'ose dire un truc et les rares
personnes qui de toute façon pas plus
mal non c'est dommage parce que de temps
en temps les rares personnes qui osent
émettre une idée tout de suite son son
taxi et leur dire oui l'heure juste un
facho lui s'éteint un extrait me to be
stars et enfin je veux dire d'être toute
personne qui sort du rang qui s'exprime
en fait toute personne qui s'exprime
tout bêtement immédiatement les
cataloguer et et vilipendé et c'est
vraiment dommage parce que sur des tas
de sujets par exemple on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure mais par
exemple sur l'islam est impossible pour
l'instant je me souviens par exemple de
cette pauvre comédienne véronique genest
qui avait eu le malheur un jour dans une
émission de télévision de dire l'islam
me fait peur mais elle a été mais traité
plus bas que terre par tout le monde
c'était l'horreur absolue c'était
pourtant une écoute il n'y a rien de
terrifiant alliant histoire me fait peur
on peut être pourront peut être contre
on peut trouver ça débile mais je ne
sais pas on va pas la lapider pourtant a
été publique fin lapider médiatiquement
c'était uniquement ce qu'elle ait dit
oui dit cela me fait peur donc voilà
maintenant c'est plus personne n'osera
je dire l'islam me fait peur c'est fini
plus j'entend personne dire ça le
problème là ce que vous évoquez sait
plus sur les problématiques des réseaux
sociaux ou s'il y est c'est fait lapider
c'est peut-être sur les réseaux sociaux
un noyau et la plage et et le problème
des réseaux sociaux c'est qu' à aucun
débat en fait ce sont des ondes affiche
une opinion dit quelque chose mais il ya
là et bien sûr les résultats c'est
l'expression qui parfois même il peut
qui dépasse presque les mains ne sais
pas c'est un jugement qu'on peut avoir
sur les réseaux sociaux on dit quand
même tout et n'importe quoi surtout
n'importe quoi bien sûr donc c'est ce
qui fait partie de la liberté
d'expression très bien chacun puisse
dire n'importe quoi
oui à condition qu'on puisse accompli
que vous voulez c'est à dire le
contraire et puis qu'ils puissent
parfois y avoir débat mais c'est vrai
nom débattre sur les réseaux sociaux
sont puisse avoir une liberté
d'expression c'est pour qu'il puisse y
avoir un débat reçus parce que si jamais
il dit quelque chose
et puis quel intérêt de faire vivre
il va telle expression donc dedans musée
parce que l'autocensure effectivement
mène à la mort les vertes expression
ensuite sur les réseaux sociaux et la
technologie en fait l'impact 2 en parler
aussi des mesures parce que c'est
important la rue mais l'impact de la
technologie c'est très très intéressant
fait parce que il me semble mais c'est
mon point de vue que justement
l'individu n'a jamais eu autant de
moyens technologiques de s'exprimer à
grande échelle qu'aujourd'hui et que
d'une certaine manière inversement
proportionnel mans il n'y a jamais eu
autant de limites à la liberté
d'expression parce que comme vous l'avez
très justement dit en fait on peut pas
dire grand chose alors évidemment je
parle pas de tous les intervenants qui
s'expriment masqué ferrandi en proférant
des insultes bon c'est pas vraiment
c'est plus de liberté d'expression non
mais je parle de liberté d'expression
sert d'opinion en fait d'opinions la vie
sur des sujets quels qu'ils soient
vous constaterez que finalement peu de
personnes a le visage découvert à noms
donnés s'exprime sur des sujets qui
prêtent à controverse
est ce que la liberté d'expression
justement suppose qu'on ne faut pas
anonyme me semble vain de semble mais
bon on est sinon on est dans des maisons
d'autres choses là qui rappellent des
nas est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
mesures d' insulte de choses violentes
qui se disent sur le socio sous couvert
de l'anonymat quand même voilà mais
encore une fois bon l'insu l'injure
également c'est assez classique ses
classiques et puis ça ça à l'intérêt
limité dans le débat me semble-t-il sur
la liberté d'expression
le vrai débat c'est encore une fois la
possibilité de s'exprimer sur des sujets
par définition qui prêtent à controverse
et qui donc
mérite qu'on s'exprime librement donc
tous les sujets compliqués les rapports
entre les hommes et les femmes les
religions enfin tous les sujets
compliqués sinon si c'est bien voilà
est-ce que vous pensez que cette couleur
anthracite double ou oui non voilà oui
mais bon c'est à moi qu'il faut la faire
vivre son débattre il faut du
contradictoire
il faudrait séparer et il faut surtout
accepter que on a le droit
sauf quand c'est interdit de donner son
opinion sur tous les sujets dans tous
les sujets à partir du moment où ce
n'est pas le cas d'ailleurs bon je veux
pas rentrer dans la technique mais pour
faire la synthèse de ces recherches en
fait moi c'était ma matière c'est la
liberté de faire le ce sujet là donc
j'ai fait quand même pas mal de
recherches fait de rechercher il a pris
brisgau de choses en faisant ça vous
vous rendez compte que le gardien de la
liberté d'expression aujourd'hui c'est
la européenne des droits de l'homme la
cod h pour parler dans un jargon un
petit peu en grand bien c'était dur à
comprendre et et vous vous rendez compte
que elle et elle est très stricte sur ce
principe avec eux il faut vraiment qu'il
y ait débat sur le respect de la liberté
a estimé très respectable et enfin ce
qui intéressait ce que peut-être plus
que les jeunes direction-là jazeera rien
de gestion nationale ne protège plus à
part le conseil constitue donc
maintenant les deux grands protecteurs
conseil constitutionnel et cour de
cassation un petit peu et puis et
surtout cdh est en fait vous vous rendez
compte que la liberté d'expression est
absolue sauf quand elle ne l'est pas et
en tout état de cause même quand elle
est justifiée ça s'appelle une atteinte
à la liberté d'expression
ça c'est quand même c'est bien de
conserver ça c'est une atteinte
injustifiée mais c'est une atteinte
j'apprends à ce que nous disaient tous
les deux
tradition et jean-charles johnny vous
n'êtes pas loin de ce qui est dit on
ferait c'est à dire qu on est plus en
démocratie on peut plus dire ce qu'on
veut en aiguille appelle ça la
démocrature qui est entre la démocratie
et les dictatures jean charles lajoie ni
et michel onfray même coup les congas
voilà on veut pas dire qu'on est contre
leur exemple on ne peut pas le dire par
exemple moi je suis à fond il ya
beaucoup de gens que lesdits
personnellement contre la peine de mort
par exemple mais je conçois tout à fait
on puisse être pour choisir s'est éteint
à terme c'est un débat le débat n'a pas
lieu d'être en france et en ce moment et
tant mieux monsieur dire on peut
discuter la pénurie mais en fait on peut
jamais discuté de la peine de mort parce
que automatiquement tous les gens qui
disent je suis pour la peine de mort
c'est très difficile et il ya comme ça
des tas de position et toutes les
positions qu'ils avaient sur les grands
débats sociétaux récent faire qu'il
était impossible d'être contre l'espèce
de normes consiste à dire ah bah non
mais si de mariage pour tous c'est
génial bon bien sûr que c'est génial
mais si quelqu'un disait cépages énerve
tout petit ah bon alors lui font la
menace a été très difficile ça a été
très difficile tout tout tout tout les
gens qui sont catalogués et et j'ai
vraiment mis dans des casses tandem
roman s'exprimer ils ont pu manifester
mais tout de suite mais mais on voit
bien comme on les traite et comment elle
est dangereuse et si les gens étaient
catalogués soit on soit catalogué par
rapport à ce qu'on pense pourquoi pas
s'est indigné le parti de la liberté ici
dans le rôle de super glam c'est qu'on
va vers l'interdiction en fait c'est ça
qui est grave en fait quand on fait du
droit là vraiment c'est que on va vers
l'interdiction pratiquement
l'interdiction de fait de quelques de
quoi par exemple ne pas pouvoir
s'exprimer
typiquement puisque vous avez pris
l'exemple sur l'islam et ça pour être
vrai sur n'importe quelle religion
on a le droit d'avoir une approche
critique de n'importe quelle religion
oui
point final donc ce qui est interdit
c'est pas de critiquer l'islam c'est pas
de ne pas aimer l'islam en dame
de ne pas aimer l'islam on n'a pas le
droit d'inciter à la haine
le centre les musulmans donc voilà et en
fait parce que la crise est le problème
la critique des pollutions situation la
haine du nord et les goristes jansson
cetera qui faisait voler duo c'est un
des piliers de la liberté dans ma fait
sauf que dans les faits à partir du
moment où est ce qu'on a c'est nous tous
oui mais c'est pas qu'on confond c'est
que la technologie permet justement à
chacun il suffit qu'une personne suivie
disent ouais c'est scandaleux et cetera
il ya tout de suite 100 1000 followers
et ça fait tâche
effectivement tâche d'huile et c'est
terminé mais donc il suffit en fait
maintenant donc ça que c'est un outil
fabuleux en fait aussi les réseaux
sociaux pour finalement empêché les gens
de s'exprimer en jetant immédiatement
l'opprobre sur une personne en disant
voilà on va en parler peut-être ça fait
peut-être bien sûr notre sujet mais
absolument
il a dit ça donc il est donc ils
incitent à la haine c'est écrit voilà
alors que quand on lit les termes oui
mais c'est parce qu'on confond laisser
non mais on peut pas empêcher les
joueurs de dire il incite et donc crpc
crédit qu'est l'islam ce n'est pas être
raciste sont deux choses différentes et
classiques comme critiquer l'homme
critiquent et patricia niçois comme
critique et le brésil et jean charles
gil enfin presque pire que
l'interdiction c'est l'interdiction
intériorisé c'est l'autocensure
c'est une forme de trouille c'est lâche
6 et éboué et de lâcheté et sans les
jambes je reviens ce que dit on ferait
quand est ce que vous pensez que le fait
que voilà il parle de n'ai parlé
notamment de l'europe en termes comment
on peut pas être contre l'europe parce
que si on est contre l'europe on nous
dit qu'on des nationalistes sur des
spécialistes
on nous dit qu'on est pour la guerre et
c'est pour ça qu'il ya quand même chape
de plomb pensée unique
je suis passé une fois ci font que sa
propre armée je crois qu'il attend plus
de gens qui sont contre l'europe comme
pour généralement par exemple mais non
je pensais qu'on avait quand même on n'a
pas
ça veut dire ça parce que vous savez
nous on n'a pas de liberté d'expression
parce qu'il ya une autocensure le poids
d'une pensée unique qui ferait qu' on
peut plus s'exprimer
un pro de la dtcc exactement la même
chose à peu près au début de l'affairé
wayne stein et du mouvement mitu toute
l'ailé au début tout discours dissonant
était absolument interdit
c'est à dire que une personne homme ou
femme qui disait pas peut-être faut
peut-être attendre un peu la pression
des sondages aussi bien non mais la
présomption d'innocence peut être ça
existe balancer des noms c'est peut-être
curieux et c'est là tout de suite
c'était à paris nos malheurs ça c'est
scandaleux et c'est qu'on ne pouvait pas
c'est que c'est quand ils sont une
aubaine difficilement audible non c'est
une chose mais ça ne les savait faux est
interdit de faire pression sociale à cet
article non mais bien sûr mais les deux
cette pression sociale va découlera un
jour enfin une réduction de 20 des
récentes pardon devrait redire en fait
mais je pense que c'est pas tellement
qu'ils aient une pensée unique comme ça
qu'ils seraient immanente qui
viendraient fabriqué en fait part grâce
au pouvoir en fait à mon avis de
l'internet et des réseaux sociaux qui
fait qu'il ya des influenceurs et ça va
très très vite
il suffit que quelqu'un va d'ailleurs
enfin c'est comme ça que des mouvements
sont lancés alors ça peut être vertueux
de ce que je suis je en train de dire
ces fossiles au talent il faut bien bien
préciser des choses c'est pas parce
qu'on déforme la possibilité d'exprimer
quelque chose qu'on le soutient cette
cassure bien sûr bien sûr évidemment non
mais on veut protéger toi p voilà c'est
sûr c'est pas parce qu'on défend quand
on a un avocat oui 1-1 criminelles pour
le contrôle que ce qu'il a fait c'est
que ce qu'elle a fait c'est jaguar mais
c'est vrai que ce pouvoir de jalibert
d'influencé immédiatement à grande
échelle fait que d'une certaine manière
oui forcément tout propos déplaira à
quelqu'un qui peut twitté et est balancé
un truc et ça c'est très très très grave
en fait que ça soit possible mais voilà
c'est encore une fois je
je n'empêche pas non plus les gens de
s'exprimer mais je dis je constate
simplement que c'est à mon avis très
intimement liés à ceux à ce pouvoir là
quand les gens avant ce qui pouvait
s'exprimer c'est les journalistes il
écrivait dans les colonnes des journaux
voilà et le garde maintenant le gâteau
il y résister au café du commerce et
puis c'est tout il y avait un truc grave
je suis pas d'accord maintenant ça s'est
démocratisée maintenant voilà vous
faites un tweet vous êtes suivi par un
gars qui en thaïlande
voilà donc à partir du moment où vous
considérez que des propos quels qu'ils
soient déplairont forcément à des
individus et que ces individus auront
les moyens de réagir avec tout le monde
en envoyant à dix mille autres c'est ben
voilà on en arrive à ça à mon avis c'est
c'est vraiment un truc est très
important oui mais il faut répondre
espace est aussi beaucoup de gens qui se
retire aussi des réseaux sociaux csn est
donc bon là mais j'ai encore une fois je
vais quand je dis ça je dis pas que
c'est pas bien sociaux c'est juste que
je je fais vraiment un lien entre ce sas
qui fait que les mêmes les journalistes
ont une certaine manière à la traîne
maintenant ils n'ont même plus pouvoir
jouer à dire d'être aligné des
initiateurs en fait de pas forcément des
informations et même de la manière dont
on les délivre ce qui fait qu'ils sont
aussi à la traîne donc vous avez dans le
sur les chaînes d'info ils sont obligés
de reprendre les tweets et jara et puis
sont à la traîne et puis voilà donc
c'est vraiment intéressant dès 9 heures
d'où vient l'information qui la
fabriquent tous là qui la manipulent ou
pas va caler de calais c'est là qu'elle
vérifie on peut prendre un exemple
concret cc c'est un sur facebook c'est
le petit lob qui étonne vos collègues
qui laurent bouvet professeur de
sciences politiques sciences politiques
les blagues et un ami un ami et je dis
est un défenseur à ses ardents de la
laïcité
oui oui oui c'est l'un de ces l'un de
ses cousins
voilà et l or il a publié une photo de
la présidente de l'unef de paris iv
voilà qu'on voit et en disant un unef
qu'on vers la convergence des luttes est
bien entamée c'est le président du
syndicat l'université paris sorbonne qui
le dit en effet alors ce qui ce qui ce
qui fait le sel de ce de ce commentaire
c'est évidemment la tenue
de cette jeune femme ça a suscité une
polémique énorme une fin pas une
polémique parce que on serait dans la
polémique
j'allais dire on serait dans l'ordre du
correct une polémique c'est plutôt sain
là on est dans une espèce de chasse à
l'homme ou magie oui oui oui de chasse à
l'homme et puis 2-2 d'insultés de
menaces jeu voilà enfin ça va très loin
nous avons extrait de mon arrêt contre
votre contre laurent bouvet lui-même il
a même reçu des menaces de mort donc on
n'est pas dans la polémique
on est au delà on n'est pas dans la
polémique acceptable est bienvenue mais
on est dans quelque chose qui
outrepassent les limites à la fois de
l'acceptable et puis de la loi aussi je
trouve que le cessèrent rejoint
exactement ce dont nous parlions à
l'instant c'est à dire que comme ça en
un quart de seconde
lisez le texte où se trouve ici
l'incitation à la haine le racisme
l'islamophobie etc
il a il a fait un interview au figaro
boxe et je vais ddv la question n'est
pas de savoir si ça me choque pas
qu'elle pourtant voilà ça c'est une
question du voile c'est une autre
question c'est pas c'est pas mon
problème il dit la question c'est que
elle elle est la présence d'un syndicat
étudiant de gauche qui affiche des
principes progressiste et féministe
lévesque est alors qu elle est vêtue
d'un voile qu'il laisse voir que l'ovale
de son visage donc qui indique
ostensiblement non seulement son
appartenance religieuse mais une
croyance particulière strictes aux
saints de l'islam
sakho m'a sauté aux yeux dit-il alors
d'accord
pas d'opposition autres on peut avoir un
voyant cette photo c'est illyriens de
rien qui ne soit totalement exacte elle
est effectivement voilée on voit
effectivement un bout de son visage ça
veut dire qu'elle est même assez ancré
dans une une partie de cette religion je
n'ai pas la plus ouverte pas passer
c'est une équipe d'une religion qui peut
être très ouverte
j'ai pas exception parce que j'ai dit à
manger un petit clic et est ancré dans
une partie de la religion
non non ne nous affolons pas sa jeune
carrière je ne peux rien dire sur les
femmes s'habillent et ce qui est
d'ailleurs disent pas du tout pour
l'interdiction du voile
l'exercice est important de la ajouté
c'est que laurent défend une position
qui n'est pas unanime qui consiste à
faire valoir que la loi de 2004 vous
savez qui interdit les signes religieux
ostensibles dans l'enseignement public
secondaires et primaires n'est pas
applicable à l'université il a été
question notamment manuel valls y ait eu
des s'était demandé si son célèbre et
opportun de l'étang dans l'enseignement
supérieur et laurent bouvet toujours eu
une position extrêmement claire là
dessus en disant pas nous nous non là on
s'adresse dans nos amphithéâtres
universitaire à des adultes qui ont une
maturité intellectuelle une maturité
entre guillemets morale qui est
suffisante pour pouvoir accepter
des signes ostensibles ostentatoire il
ya des universités qui ont d'ailleurs
des études un nombre assez important
d'étudiants qui arborent des signes de
quelques religion qu'ils soient dès lors
que le débat est toujours possible dès
lors que le respect s'impose toujours et
globalement on y parvient donc de ce
point de vue là laurent vraiment défend
une position qui contredit ouvertes les
insultes qu'on lui envoie aujourd hui à
la phase 6 n'est pas la liste east lake
à la ici ce que je ne sais pas si on
enlève la troisième république bon non
non il est pas d'un troisième
non mais non mais non ce qui dit elle
parce que c'est ça qui est important
pourquoi la convergence des luttes pas
ce qu'il dit c'est ce qui pose problème
c'est la question de l'acceptation de
d'être représenté par une jeune femme
qui affiche ses convictions religieuses
que ce qui me pose problème c'est que
c'est que le 9 accepte d'être les choses
ont bien changé et c'est ça ou on a une
réaction
l'unef n'est plus ce qu'elle était ou ce
qu'elle fut et
c'est vrai l'unef a d'ailleurs effacé de
son compte twitter des des tracts ou des
messages qui montrait à quel point ce
syndicat était en pointe dans la défense
des droits des femmes de l'émancipation
des femmes dans la défense de la laïcité
de lits vg et c est de voir maintenant
des engagements 20 ou 25 ans plus tard
de voir ce à titre symbolique
ce que ce que l'unef est devenu car vous
avez bien résumé les choses ne se
souviendrait je ne dis pas tout fout
l'camp j'ai dit le fondateur de lunettes
il ya un autre problème qui est un
problème plus compliqué qui est ce que
est ce que l'islam est en train aussi
pénétré dans l'université
c'est une des questions enfin c'est une
des questions cause de laurent beauvais
oui il faudrait faire des études pour
savoir ce qui ce qui ce qui est juste
c'est que l'unef à des noyaux certain
nombre de plateaux d accord avec eux les
étudiants musulmans de france sur
l'organisation de certains événements
etc
enfin il le dit d'ailleurs il va pas
plus loin il pose la question sans pour
autant donner la réponse
ce qui veut dire que le débat reste
ouvert vincent râler sur vous
la laïcité vous en parlait dans le libre
ils sont consacrés en quoi c'est un
problème de liberté d'expression liberté
d'expression parce que dans l'acception
large de l'expression il ya la manière
d'afficher certaines de ses convictions
religieuses et ça fait partie de deux de
la liberté d'expression et vous avez des
débats sur la laïcité en entreprise des
jurisprudences pour savoir si il ya un
cas assez récents qui a été tranché par
la cndh de manière
un petit peu particulière on va dire
mais favorable aux honorables c'est un
peu un peu plus compliqué nécessaire de
dire qu' il fallait qu'il raison en fait
pour c'était un cas où il y avait une
jeune femme qui était en relation pas
avec la clientèle en fan de l'entreprise
c'était un peu le pivot du des critères
retenus mais mais encore une fois pour
revenir juste sur ce sujet là évidemment
là on glisse seront glissés sur le fond
du sujet ça reste que l'islam ceci ou
cela mais à la limite peu importe
en tout cas pour moi c'est pas le sujet
vous pouvez être d'accord pas d'accord
mais est ce qu'on a le droit de le dire
simplement est ce qu'on a le droit de
penser le dire est ce qu'on a le droit
d'avoir un avis là dessus est ce qu'on a
le droit de dire que par exemple les
payeurs à l'islam politique est que l'on
trouve que c'est inquiétant qu'on en
veut qu'on n'en veut pas c'est ça le
sujet alors il faut aujourd'hui c'est un
sujet dit cela parce qu'on vit dans un
monde on peut pas se voiler la face nous
avec avec ce qui se passe dans le monde
aujourd'hui mais le sujet pour exposer
avec n'importe quelle autre religion
n'importe quel autre système de pensée
voilà at on le droit de s'exprimer sur
des enjeux sociétaux une organisation de
la société des influences de pensée de
philosophie et d'avoir un avis là dessus
c'est ça le sujet ait donné l'arrivée de
m ah ben moi oui mais que le droit dit
c'est oui je sais c'est le coeur de
bercy c'est le débat politique oui donc
là apparemment d'après ce que je
comprends votre collègue pense
qu'effectivement c'est une forme de
l'islam politique qui commence à arriver
il le pense il le dit il a le droit de
le penser et de le dire point savoir si
c'est vrai si c'est pas vrai si on est
d'accord si on n'est pas d'accord est un
autre sujet et d'ailleurs
voilà enfin je pense que mes gars la
polémique serait que le fixer mais là
c'est pas c'est pas pour ça que le fait
d'avoir cette idée là les caricatures de
charlie hebdo il ya eu des jugements
il est des procès le cheikh lors ils ont
payé extrêmement cher mais pas par le
droit le droit reconnu le droit à la
caricature
oui le droit au blasphème droit passé
par là juridiquement et 7 c'est pas le
droit placente diable ne reconnaît pas
de belge a pas réservé le droit
d'acquérir donc et en fait on confond
aujourd'hui en fait pour faire court
toutes les personnes sans visée qui que
ce soit qui ont intérêt en fait à
instrumentaliser la liberté d'expression
où les limites à la liberté d'expression
dans un intérêt communautariste quel
qu'il soit
les associations de l'inde jardin ce que
vous voulez vont utiliser ressemblant de
prendre n'importe quel propos de le
prendre au premier degré en réagissant
de manière extrêmement violente et en
mettant tout de suite haine contre et
voilà c'est tellement gros si vous
voulez que mais ça fonctionne puisque
grâce à l'informatique et internet
de toute façon on peut pas l'empêcher il
est tout de suite 100 mille personnes
dix mille personnes etc
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans nos
sociétés il ya une communautarisation
mais qui c'est qui a fait que justement
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les gens
réagissent par atteinte à un effet les
propriétaires de nains de jardin qui ne
supportera pas parce que je pense que
l'aîné est ce que parce que c'est parce
que je pense qu'il ya eu un il ya une
forme d'échec aussi en partie 2 j'allais
dire de deux je veux pas dire de la
république mais quelque part je le pense
c'est à dire l'incapacité de
l'incapacité à la république de vivre
pleinement et que j'allais dire de de
s'imposer dans le coeur des gens en fait
mais voilà donc effectivement il des
gens à juste titre qu'ils se sentent
exclus des rails qui n'ont plus d'eau
disent combien on a beaucoup parlé de la
république de la source sociales et des
vertus républicaines des valeurs
républicaines mais ça marche pas
tellement dans le c'est pour ça que
les gens ont besoin de s'exprimer
autrement et donc il ya des
revendications communautaristes
ce qui est assez curieux aussi c'est
qu'on a quand même toujours besoin et
vous venez de le trouver de de prendre
des précautions ses terres que là on
parle de l'islam est tout de suite on
dit oui mais ça serait pareil pour les
nains de jardin et passion pas d'aidé
ils ont parlé des nains de jardin il
redresse et musulmans j'ai déjà blessé
par l'islam on pourrait discuter des
nains de jardin c'est pas sa communauté
à tout le monde pose tout le monde mais
pas le voile tout le monde voilà donc ça
veut rien dire on ne peut pas discuter
de façon presque détendu puisque tout de
suite il faut le dire il faut faire
attention c'est un peu comme si on
parlait de plus si on parle de l'islam
on ne se croit toujours objet de
préciser et c'est comme un autre
problème avec toutes les autres
religions que ça pourrait poser
on est toujours obligé de prendre ses
précautions oratoires qu'on ne prendrait
pas si on avait un même débat sur l'île
sur le bouddhisme mais personne ne
dirait et là on parle du bouddhisme et
on fait ça pour être la même chose on
n'aurait pas besoin n'auraient
pratiquement moins d'attentes au moins
deux se disent je suis bien d'accord sûr
pas les bouddhistes on n'aurait pas
laissé pour sa reddition
un petit peu comme
la dernière fois dans votre excellente
émission sur sur la sphère texte où
effectivement quand il y avait eu cette
blague de live c'était justement parce
qu'il y avait un contexte
aujourd'hui il ya un problème avec les
attentes a donc forcément l'islam se
trouve plus au coeur du sujet que ce
l'on vivait dans un autre monde voilà
c'est tout sur le tweet il reprend les
mots de la présidente qui dit c'est la
convergence des luttes et je pense que
là dessus il ya un dérapage évident
parce que là elle parle des cheminots
d'état est en fait au travers de ça on
peut dire complètement autre chose si on
a envie de lire autre chose
oui ben tu vois bah oui puisqu'il ya en
fait quand on a si on ne sait pas si on
vous la trouvez comment
non mais c'est allé lui présente une
photo avec une femme voilée qui est
présidente du syndicat de l'unaf et ça
commence par à l'unef
la convergence des luttes est bien
entamée et quand on fait le lien entre
cette phrase-là et la photo on peut se
poser la question de savoir ce qu'il ya
derrière
parce que là ce qu'elle dit elle par de
la convergence des luttes en ce moment
par rapport aux grèves qui se déroule en
france mais hong ran esprits tordus non
celui qui sait la lutte ayant si ça
tient et vous qu'est-ce que vous non
parce que date quand il est la façon
dont cet écrit à l'unef la convergence
des luttes et bien dans ta n'est point
c'est la présidente du syndicat
l'université paris sorbonne qui le dit
mais en fait on retient je sais pas si
c'est son des balles et raquettes
qu'elle appelle quelques
suivant différents une fille devait
malawi tarifaire des roches sur cette
convergence justement mais qu'elles
luttent encore pour moi peu importe
c'est à dire que il a le droit il a le
droit de ne pas aimer l'islam
je suis désolé de dire je le dis ouais
un fil mais on a le droit de ne pas
aimer l'islam ce qu'on n'a pas le droit
de le faire c'est de ne pas aimer les
musulmans cc alors on va dire ben oui
mais c'est pareil
oui si c'est par ici on dit que c'est
pareil on n'a eu qu'une opinion sur
aucun sujet aucun donc c'est très
important d'ailleurs l'annoncé d'un
changement dia sur fond la jurisprudence
boutin
l'homosexualité est une abomination
à la fin la cour de cassation relax
parce que c'est pas les homosexuels
c'est le l'homosexualité c'est un
jugement de valeur ça ça les regarde
mais elle peut importe c'est son
problème mais voilà donc oui le lac est
ce que voulait dire aussi c'est qu'il
faudrait il faudrait qu'on arrive à
accepter ce que d'autres pensent qu'on
ne pense pas oui c'est vrai ce que
l'autre pense c'est simplement qu'on a
le droit de penser progrès comme eric on
a le droit de penser on a besoin de dire
il y en a le droit de dire des bras
droit de faire des discours des bouquins
sur l'islam sur un autre sujet parce que
je veux pas qu'on ait l'impression que
c'est que la liberté d'expression c'est
que l'islam ce n'est pas que ça c'est un
sujet mais il y en a plein d'autres pour
ça que je mets mais effectivement on a
le droit de temps à droite pas aimé de
tous styles y sont à droite pas aimer
d'islam voilà après si dans la manière
dont on exprime sa si on veut critiquer
on glisse vers finalement quelque chose
qui va inciter les gens à avoir de
l'animosité contre les personnes qui
elles sont d adèle ou apprécié larmes
d'autres choses donc effectivement 16e
manière après de le dire il ya une
manière de le si si ça devient un hit
motif
et puis que ça glisse là on arrive là
dedans
après quand si on a un discours
simplement j'avais politique sur un
sujet
quel qu'il soit et que on prend bien
garde de ne pas faire l'amalgamé avec
les personnes on doit évidemment pouvoir
être libre de l'exprimer faire voilà c
c'est fin c'est pas mon avis en fait
c'est le droit et qu'ils disent sauf que
aujourd'hui encore une fois on l'oubli
pour ça que ce code pardon de revenir
avant d'ouvragé je suis un petit peu de
promo c'est l'emballage code et c'est de
ce code est un manifeste aussi c'est un
manifeste un manifeste pour la liberté
exprès c'est ce que je vous demande et
vous c'est ça la manif derrière derrière
les allemands on va dire la ccl
juridique c'est les résidences en voilà
il ya peu de il ya peu c'est une des
choses qui sont en travers la liberté
expression c'est très très fort c'est la
substantifique moelle
voilà il ya ce sont les grands princes
il ya quelques traités et voilà la
déclaration des droits de l'homme c'est
parce que ça se suffit voilà on est
libre de s'exprimer d'exprimer une
opinion points c'est ça c'est sacré
voilà et ensuite après effectivement il
ya un an avant d interdiction parce
qu'il faut qu'on puisse vivre ensemble
et que des gens dépassent les limites
ces drames et à chaque fois à chaque
fois à chaque fois il faut faire
attention à chaque fois qu'on l'appliqué
il faut bien être dans les critères de
proportionnalité et c2 de respect de la
loi voilà et et surtout méfions-nous à
chaque fois que de nouvelles
interdictions et à chaque fois qu'on l'a
conteste il faut essayer des pipots à la
pousser derrière par exemple la critique
des religions et le racisme qui sont
deux choses totalement différentes je ne
vois pas le rapport moi personnellement
non mais vous avez souvent qu'elle des
gens qui critique des religions qui sont
racistes payer des vidéos partout y en a
qui vont penser que tous les amalgames
c'est que tous les gens qui ont des sons
en costumes sont des bourgeois qui
veulent les autres qu'ils ont reçus sont
riches et qui est et qui exploitent les
ions tout ce qu'on dit quoique
je travaille pour particuliers sur condé
cravate club
notez bien sûr éclater enfin fasciste au
fond voilà bah oui puisqu'on a le droit
de tout dire par exemple michel enfin
qu'il dit emmanuel macron très embêtant
gamin parce qu'il prend la main de sa
femme
ben c'est pas drôle c'est pas
intelligent mais il a le droit de le
séparer de roue lors du ces c'est plutôt
ça manque de subtilité mais il ya le
droit de le dire
cette relation ça n'a aucun intérêt
surtout sa femme et les deux hommes
promet donc c'est une analyse pertinente
sur cette déclaration là en ce qui me
concerne la c'est un jugement de valeur
c'est une opinion personnelle c'est je
suis beaucoup plus choqué de voir des
journalistes pendant qu'ils interviewent
le président de la république sur une
grande chaîne de télévision en lui
disant emmanuel macron oui comme ça
là ça ça me choque plus meyer en tant
que doyen que deux
michel onfray qui va dire c'est un gamin
oui mais voilà par exemple mais ça c'est
seulement une opinion c'est une opinion
totalement personnelle mais il ya quand
même des alors les textes sont assez peu
appliquée par la présidence de la
république en place mais il ya des
atteintes au président lee a lancé pas
là on est on n'est pas dedans est passé
si on voulait d'abord strictement ça
pourrait être une offense non
[Musique]
c'est pas une injure mais voilà après
bon cessé mais méfions nous quand même 2
voilà il faut il faut la faire vivre
cette liberté d'expression qu'il faut il
faut donner c'est à dire ses opinions
évidemment il faut réfléchir faut pas
blesser faux pas mais mais on a le droit
de dire ce que l'on pense sur des sujets
qui sont des sujets qui qui sont des
sujets de débats en fait tout sujet qui
prête à un débat doit pouvoir être
existé en fait et être débattue à la
déclaration de michel onfray la non mais
ça il est un gamin président de la
république à 40 en bas on peut dire
qu'on pense que c'est un gamin c'est pas
forcément dire que je ratisse amène
rencontrèrent laudatif à gamin est
arrivé dans la république
mais je crois que c'est la vie de sophie
qui faisait après voilà bon jeu la loi
schiappa justement est-ce que ça pose
des problèmes de liberté d'expression
c'est pas des problèmes divers
d'expression il ya envoyé plusieurs
choses dans la loi d'ailleurs mais il ya
pas mal de choses sont encore une fois
alors je sais pas si vous voulez qu'on
parle de la polémique
vous voulez dire ça c'est autre chose
c'est un peu différent
non je parle est plutôt noir seulement 2
rue de pas si vous voulez alors déjà
quand on quand on parle de quand on
parle de harcèlement de rue on donne
déjà un utilisateur qui lui même et est
délictueux en fait délictuel le
harcèlement doit bien dire qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ses intérêts c'est pas
bien il faut pas le faire
ah ça c'est ma première réaction est
fort ce les personnes donc pas des
femmes mais mais les personnes déjà le
harcèlement c'est pas bien même donc que
on constate qu'il ya un problème c'est
évident bien sûr que ça existe et que
c'est un problème il y en a plein
d'autres je pense que c'est un problème
d'abord d'éducation personnellement non
mais parce qu'ils exigent alors après
l'action comme comme ce que disent
jean-charles tout à l'heure des gens
qu'il dise voilà enfin du coup on peut
plus rien faire on ne peut rien dire
oui bah après je sais pas moi je connais
pas les tenants et les aboutissants de
jeu comment ça pourrait être
caractérisée qui et c'est ce qui a des
paroles qui seront interdites est ce
qu'il ya des as et tout est dans
l'attitude c'est tout c'est tout ce que
je sais tout propos à caractère sexy
c'était un peu plus il avait encore une
fois mais là encore je suis pas contre
haut pour enfin je veux dire je ne sais
pas rendrait vie
éclairer un peu le jeu je pense que
toute façon c'est pas bien de
d'apostrophés des gens et en particulier
des femmes en or de donc bon voilà après
est-ce qu'il faut un texte pour ça je ne
sais pas c'est ça la question c'est
jusqu'où il doit aller est ce qu'on doit
en faire un texte est ce que lui sera
appliquée parce que il faut aussi voir à
partir du moment où vous avez des
individus et peut-il se permettre ce
genre de choses je suis pas sûr qu'une
contravention de 90 euros c'était avec
le policier qui va voir va empêcher des
jeunes quand ils veulent le faire d'eux
des jeunes ou pas d'ailleurs je
stigmatise des vues ici les lieux mêmes
des vieux bourgeois de neuilly
voilà en cravate prendre en cravate club
20 lles voilà c'est que ce n'est pas la
question la seule mais donc je sais plus
si vous voulez c'est l'applicabilité il
ya des gens envoyés par mail des gens
quand vous avez un deux roues
ils s'asseyent sur votre deux roues ou
alors ils mangent dessus sur la seule
équipe dégueulasse votre selle pour
consoles alors attendez c'est quand même
grave des millions de femmes subissent
assez rapides donc je suis pas ouais ce
que je veux juste dire c'est que c'est
pas bien
effectivement il faut essayer de faire
en sorte que dans notre société y est
plus ce type de comportement réseau de
l'éducation
je suis dubitatif sur à la fois
l'application surtout l'efficacité et
l'efficacité de ce type de mesure parce
que dans ce type de d'interdiction aussi
il ya un aspect comment dire
je cherche mon mot peu incitatif et
n'inverse produits beatty phase
d'avertissement fait d'eux des d'ériger
une incisive wallace manquons à un
professeur
voilà et donc je ne suis pas sûr soul et
de l'effet dissuasif
voilà il ya voyez par exemple sur le
voile il semblait qu'il y avait une loi
qui interdisait le voile intégral c'est
bon voilà hier soir j'étais venue de
versailles et j'ai choisi mes courses et
il y avait une femme qui était en voile
intégral noir avec simplement deux les
yeux alors à la bombe et des policiers
en scooter c'est vrai pourquoi la donc
générale il ya des textes et praia
l'application donc là évidemment je
pense que ça sera plus facile
je pense que ça sera plus facile de
verbalisé un avis du sol qui a fait ça
je pense que là pour le coup ça la loi
serait appliquée mais voilà je suis pas
sûr que ça aidera beaucoup les femmes
et voilà mais bon je n'ai pas plus
d'avis que ça je veux dire aussi si
c'est si c'est un signe qu'on donne je
le prends comme ça et c'est plutôt un
bon signe dans le principe au nom je
vois comment ça peut être appliquée dans
les faits non mais il veut rentrer dans
la conscience des gens des gens qui sait
peut-être que ça va voir
dissuasif ou alors que voilà deux
peut-être que certains trouveront la
langue sept fois dans sa bouche est
ronde et fade dans des cercles familiaux
voilà quelle école ils s'appellent jeudi
fait le poids par les pairs je suis pas
sûr que ce soit ça qui fasse vraiment
avancer le alors on a fêté mais c'est
peut-être pas le bout le premier
anniversaire de la nomination de
d'edouard philippe à matignon
comment me trouver comme premier
ministre notre ami de droite très bien
c'est pas vous qui se dit çà c'était le
titre du non pas besoin j'ai
l'impression qu'il fait bien le job
enfin il a l'air de bien s'entendre en
plus avec le président c'est quand même
un peu je le dépose en terre cuite et
qui portait sur l'oeil sur les sur les
primaires étaient assez assez amusant
parce que au fond on se rendait compte
qu'il arrive dans le documentaire et le
maquereau non il a aucun espace jamais
la droite ya la douche est assez
classique dont tirait pas beaucoup qui
vont venir non plus dans ces wagons mais
c'est abusé enfin c'est on était en 2016
et 2017 quand même enfin c'était assez
amusant et un soleil temps et cela étant
il me semble pas ce que j'ai vu certains
extraits effectivement très mal passé il
me semble que m'ont donné il dit cela
étant moi je suis d'accord et tout ce
qui lie à la rude
oui non mais donc il a dit avoir donné
comme espace oui mais dont acte donc un
oeil au moins si c'est vrai on peut
prendre acte que il se redit par
quelques 90 ce qu'ils pensent en tout
cas y'a quand même
alors on en a vu il ya une député
bourguignon je crois il ya eu françois
bayrou qui demande quand même ce qui est
d'une dimension sociale politique et qui
est appliquée depuis un an
est-ce que vous font c'est pas mickey
glisse mais c'est plus une politique de
droite sur les deux pieds comme elle
devait être géré en même temps après
qu'ils aient des gens
dont votre ami qui ont besoin d'exister
c'est essaye de s'imposer en train de
dire oui il faudrait faire ça pour très
influent c'est un peu son boulot votre
ami jean-charles change de disque mais
je sais patrice très fidèle en amitié
mais non c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
si on reprend les mesures qui ont été
prises elles vont plutôt dans un sens
qu'au nom
oui mais aussi des mesures à mon sens en
tout cas et s imposer donc j'ai donc
mais le en même temps va venir
c'est toute la réforme sur
l'apprentissage sur la formation en 2006
sur les mêmes à savoir est ce que les
cheminots sont des gens plus privilégie
ceux qui paient l'isf mais c'est un peu
ça puisqu'on revient sur le statut des
cheminots et on se publiait sa faune
mais on se crispe alias el para tea
party les cheminots sont les premiers à
dire qui nous sommes ce ne sont pas des
privilégiés donc n'étant pas des
privilégiés ils peuvent
on peut difficilement non je pose la
question mais moi j'ai dit qu'aux
milieux comme ils déclarent tous ne pas
être d privilégie ce que je ne comprends
toujours pas comment ils peuvent râler
contre la suppression d'un statut qui
serait un statut de privilégiés qui
n'acceptent pas d'avoir enfin vous êtes
un peu peu compliqué mais voilà que moi
j'ai du mal donc je préside l'asean
correspondent à votre caisse qui sans
être la chose qui me semble être à peu
près certaine en tout cas c'est que je
ne pense pas que ce soit le statut des
cheminots qui génère les milliards de
dollars
de ce point de vue là bon je fasse je
pense que d'ailleurs tout le monde le
dit enfin voilà donc après le statut des
cheminots
la question c'est est il voué
à disparaître parce que il ailleurs
l'ouverture à la concurrence et il ya
déjà la loi et c'est bon c'est ça le
sujet peut-être que veulent pas bon
c'est ce qu'on peut comprendre mais je
pense qu'aussi derrière il ya des enjeux
beaucoup plus important pour la survie
des syndicats dans leur forme actuelle
et surtout surtout donc ça c'est un vrai
sujet c'est que je pense que le
syndicalisme en france c'est un vrai
sujet devrait il est d'ailleurs dans le
livre promotion puisque effectivement
intervention est donc évidemment il ya
une liberté d'expression syndicale mais
l'organisation des syndicats en france
peut-être est obsolète comme d'ailleurs
du patronat aussi enfin angers dont
général peut-être qu'il faudrait il
faudrait faire rage doxa et refaire un
grenelle ii dgr des relations sociales
de manière générale voilà bon mais à
chaque fois qu'on peut être un moyen de
renforcer les syndicats c'est peut-être
plus représentative plus fort mais bon
on n'a pas trouvé le moyen âgeux je n'en
dirai pas plus je sais pas du tout ma
spécialité pour votre tweet de luc ferry
qui parle de daniel cohn bendit est
alors voilà une comédie qui est au
festival de cannes de coin repos tigre
la voilà cette photo co fait mieux que
tous les arguments rationnels ce que
j'écris sur mai 68 depuis trente ans un
mouvement révolutionnaire en apparence
et libérale consumérisme petit bourgeois
en réalité merci dany c'est assez
amusant avec la photo oui je sais c'est
drôle c'est drôle et facile de dire ça
pathétique série 2 il faut qu'il soit
comment comme mais dit il faut qu'il
soit en pagne oui
en train de fumer un joint bon il a pas
le droit n'a pas pris on est plus en et
68 a conservé son côté rebelle puisqu'il
est né sharp donc oui mais pas de les
chars il a les mains dans les poches il
a le noeud papillon comme qui a parlé un
peu et à 45 degrés api ont révolutionné
voilà donc
c'est amusant et avaient saccagé des
p'tites poules voilà ces gens ils ans ça
pour ça disent une forme de boutade fait
le fait que certaines soixante huitard
soient devenus les gens qui ont gouverné
la société n'est pas de nouveau nous
privait les leaders de 68 milliards
d'euros et de macération ya un côté
rassurant c'est de voir que l'on peut
faire certaines choses à un certain âge
et bien après changé c'est dans l'ordre
et puis et puis daniel cohn bendit est
un est extrêmement brillant enfin
franchement c'est une voix qui porte
c'est quelqu'un qui résonne c'est
quelqu'un qui est globalement nuancé
dans les appréciations qu'il porte
quelqu'un de conviction enfin
franchement notamment son discours sur
l'europe avec un discours très pro c'est
un vrai européen et il alla tournage de
la vidéo ont fait justement c'est ce
discours tellement propre et ça sauf que
les gens value et ça lui a valu six
quand même de 19% oui oui mais enfin
globalement l'idée européenne
c'est celle là qui est plutôt il ya des
problèmes
économique dans les pays
vous chercher du boulot vous n'êtes pas
bien payés et qu'on vous explique c'est
super parce que l'europe
il va y avoir des règlements des
directives cédera va c'est pas très
porteur comme discours ça peut
s'expliquer aussi lu ça d'ailleurs qu'il
adhérait parce que bientôt n'est pas
venu et c'est pour ça qu'il a lu une
brique si c'est pour voilà ce qui
sélectionnaient oui ça peut s'expliquer
dès lors que vous avez des élus des
politiques qui vous disent n'importe
quoi et que ce crâne les gens paieraient
pour d'expliquer quand il ya des choses
positives qui ont un impact concret me
demandez pas densité j'en sais rien mais
des choses de se voir aussi promouvoir
il faut le faire aussi pour emmanuel
macron là ces élections européennes
parce que lui est très très
pro-européens il oeuvre beaucoup pour
lui les élections
c'est un moment pour lui un moment
important du très rapide parce qu'il
nous reste très peu de temps
cahuzac condamné mais il leur adresse
pour le moment pas en prison est ce le
canton fraudent le fisc ou faux pas
c'est pas très grave
bah quand même 80 avec 4 et 2 ans aussi
une manière de rien quand même
c'est une meilleure peine pour lui qu'en
première instance ils étaient très
contents
oui il a bien fait il a bien fait de
prendre du pendant l'été dans la cour et
mai mais il y a de la chance aussi c'est
que la loi qu'on peut aller en prison
pour des petits larcins et que non alors
ses citoyens
honnêtement oui mais j'allais aller en
prison pour fraude fiscale c'est
rarissime mais les gens voient donc ça
c'est comme le premier point donc voilà
la deuxième chose c'est que si on ne
regarde que les faits la peine est très
lourde après je ne dis pas que elle est
trop lourde
j'en sais rien je mets quand on juge au
pénal on part de fait ensuite on juge
une personne donc on juge en
considération de sa personnalité
ce qui veut dire en clair ces problèmes
personnels des faits non pas un symbole
on juge pas des faits on juge une
personne pertinents donc au niveau des
faits bon si on jugeait que les faits il
aurait pris trois fois moins il a réussi
son amende fiscale au revoir monsieur et
voilà c'est comme ça donc simplement si
c'est aussi sévère c'est que justement
ces personnes on a besoin en
considération à la fois sa personne
c'est à dire son nom son argent se sont
mensongers et en plus la situation dans
laquelle il était de notre
responsabilité est en plus de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale
donc il troubler gravement l'ordre
public ce qui pèse qui lui rappelle
simplement que les magistrats
effectivement au pénal ont une marge de
manoeuvre assez grande pour prononcer
des peines et c'est très bien comme ça
voilà on s'arrête pas parce que messi
mais on voit que les avocats de la
défense
vincent voir édition du code code de la
liberté et d'expression dans la
collection portalis essais chez anne
rideau édition merci infiniment
et cette voix là c'est un livre à mettre
en toutes les entre toutes les mains
surtout sur toi là voilà merci beaucoup
merci vous pose tes fans mention merci
beaucoup florence mercadé choqué merci
beaucoup jean charles l'a redit à
bientôt
[Musique]